this is the world's worst conflict
a war of terrifying brutality and
intensity now spreading through parts of
ethiopia the conflict in tigre has run
for nearly a year now there is a
constant flow of refugees now making
their way down to the river issued a
dire warning about the growing crisis in
ethiopia being a stain on our
consciousness it began as a battle for
political power but it has turned into a
fight to the death between prime
minister abi ahmed's national government
and the leaders of the region of tigre
and it is their forces now threatening
the country's capital addis ababa
so
does this nation of 110 million stand on
the brink of civil war
ethiopia is immense in its size and
diversity more than 80 ethnic groups
call it home
the most populous region encircling the
capital addis ababa is called aromia
amhara on the central plateau has
traditionally been a center of political
power while the region of tigre where
just six percent of the population live
lies in the north near eritrea
and it's the party that rules this
region the tigray people's liberation
front or tplf which has dominated
politics in ethiopia in recent years
seizing power in 1991 their economic
policies transformed a country
associated with famine
into an african powerhouse
but they also rigged elections and
locked up their opponents and massive
demonstrations would eventually bring
them down
the chief beneficiary of the instability
was a youthful oromo called abi ahmed
who was promoted to the top job in the
ruling coalition in 2018. this would-be
modernizer introduced a dizzying array
of political initiatives
one of them a peace deal with
neighboring eritrea would win him the
nobel peace prize
yet the journey from prize winner to war
leader has been swift
the war in tigre erupted in november
2020 after tensions between abby's
government and the tplf reached boiling
point
the prime minister launched a so-called
policing operation to remove the tplf
from power
and ethiopian soldiers with assistance
from amhara and eritrea quickly took
control of key cities like the tigrayan
capital of mckele
but the tplf regrouped and in a stunning
reversal pushed the ethiopian aligned
forces out of mckele in june
the terrain rebels have pushed on
grabbing territory in the regions of
amhara and afar
and advancing down the a2 highway they
now threaten the ethiopian capital
itself
[Music]
i think you're incredibly strong
ballet
the humanitarian cost of this conflict
is incalculable the war has fueled acts
of unspeakable violence
into grey we saw evidence of mass
killings and the destruction of villages
at the hands of ethiopian aligned forces
the 13 year old child
yes they can i see in my house
they told for the kid come he says come
and the child go to
the solder
and kill wagon and again
killed by in this area
you saw that yes
in amhara we were taken to a mass grave
where locals told us that community
members had been massacred by the tplf
a joint investigation by the un and the
state-appointed ethiopian human rights
commission said the conflict had been
marked by extreme brutality
and the un accuses the ethiopian
government of enforcing a de facto
blockade on tigray preventing shipments
of emergency food aid and medicine from
reaching the territory
aid vehicles must travel through afar
where the terrain and local people are
hostile to these shipments
humanitarian officials say there have
been no aid deliveries for weeks
as the tplf draws closer to the capital
their representatives have forged new
alliances signing a deal with insurgents
from aromia and seven other rebel groups
while ethiopia's embattled prime
minister nabi ahmed has declared a state
of emergency calling on residents of
addis ababa to prepare to defend their
neighborhoods
it's very difficult to see a way out of
this crisis because abby ahmed and the
tplf want exactly the same thing
both seek to eradicate the other
international envoys trying to
kick-start peace talks but at the moment
negotiation seems like the least likely
outcome
[Music]
you